One thing that makes humans
unique in the animal kingdom
is our unparalleled use
of complex language.
And it's a gene on chromosome 7,
known as FOXP2, that plays
a vital role in allowing
this to happen.
Humans have a characteristic
form of FOXP2 that evolved
around 200,000 years ago.
And some people have speculated
that it's this
uniquely human version of the
gene that led to the evolution
of our complex language.
Now, the case is almost
certainly more
complicated than that.
But there's a similar form of
the gene that exists in
songbirds like this canary.
Now, when the birds learn the
new song, well, the gene comes
into action.
We clearly don't fully
understand the role of FOXP2
in humans or in other animals.
But what we think at the moment
is that it plays an
important role in
neuroplasticity, and that's
the ability of the brain
to change over time.
And it's neuroplasticity that
allow songbirds like the
canary to learn such
impressive songs.